do you see that viral video from uh is
it live action or live live action live
action see I always I always say one and
then think it's the other where uh this
woman she comes in and their boss and
the manager they're like so we heard the
good news you know we heard news you're
pregnant she's like I am and they're
like let us know there's anything we can
do for you we'll get you a flight you
know whatever you need to fly out of
state you'll get you a really nice hotel
and she's like flight out of state and
I'm like right right you know when do
you think you get back to work I think
in a couple weeks and she's like uh and
then after giving birth they're like oh
we we meant you know so these companies
I think this one's obvious they want to
save money it's cheaper just have a
woman go get an abortion than it is to
actually provide benefits pay for
maternity leave as well as dependence on
the health care no it's it's being spun
as this feminist thing to pay for an
employee's abortion it's really just I
mean capitalism trying to get you back
to your nine to five which in other
circumstances feminist would oppose but
because it enables abortion they're
actually for it Kroger is one of the
places that said that they would come
and pay for abortions yeah Microsoft as
well there's a whole bunch of them I
encourage anyone who watches this to
actually look out those lists of
companies and stop shopping there
because otherwise you are literally
funding abortion that's not hyperbole
you you are financing these employees
abortions you got to vote with your
dollar I think a lot of people realize
that you have a lot more power when it
comes to deciding what you incentivize
than just going to that Ballot Box once
every four years yes so just to ask you
directly if you could have your way what
would happen how can we take action on
this how can we move forward if if you
were able to decide how we move forward
what would be the next step transparency
first of all so look the way I look at
it we live in a free country if you want
with your own money to advance an
environmental agenda or a social agenda
whatever that is pro-life agenda
pro-choice agenda whatever it is if you
want to do it with your own money we
live in a free country you're free to do
that but if you're not free to do it
with OPM okay other people's money okay
that's a special use it we talk about
that strive all the time okay you can't
do it with OPM so so if you gonna do it
with other people's money there's a
really simple standard you just need to
tell them you're doing it and you need
to get their consent so what happens
when every wealth manager every 401k
account in Corporate America every 401k
plan manager every pension fund manager
goes and asks the teacher the doctor the
nurse the engineer hey are you cool with
me using your money to vote in favor of
a racial equity-based hiring system
that's a effective quota system in
Corporate America most of them are going
to have a pretty clear answer they're
going to say hell no I'm not now for the
20 or the 10 percent who's fine with it
that's great that restores Integrity
back into the system and some of those
people are going to say you know what I
would trade off a few dollars of
investment return if you actually make
sure that these companies Embrace
pro-life causes and if you're doing with
that with your own money I'm fine with
that too but I would not be fine with an
asset manager even though I'm right of
Center it doesn't matter I don't think
an asset manager should be using
somebody else's money to fund a pro-life
cause without the capital owner actually
knowing it
transparency disclosure consent and
actually prosecute bring civil action or
otherwise against the people who violate
those principles that's the challenge
though if they're not playing by the
rules and you are they're they're
winning well I'm part of a part of the
role of a market actor is also to raise
hell and make sure that they are damn
well planned by the same rules by the
time we're done with this and so this is
this is a bottom-up revolution not in
our politics but it's it's in our Market
because people are voting every day with
their dollars they just don't think of
themselves as voting as they do once a
year when they go to The Ballot Box
every November once they realize that
though that knowledge is the first step
to actually giving them Choice make sure
the other guys feet are held to the fire
that they are playing by the same rules
we don't need to pass new laws for this
by the way most of these are violations
I believe of laws that are already on
the books basic fiduciary principles if
you're Sam bankman freed you cannot use
a customer's funds in a way that a
customer did not agree to without his
permission that's the crime on offer
well I don't care if you dress it up as
he did actually by the way too in an ESG
clothing you could say the same thing
you can't use somebody else's money to
advance your own agenda without telling
them you're doing it unless you get
their permission same principles just
got to apply those standards
even-handedly adding red states are
slowly slowly beginning to wake up to it
and I think people really need to know
about this because I would be pissed my
money is going to promote wokeness but
also more importantly I think people
need to realize you're losing money
because you're incentivizing a lot of
this nonsense that doesn't make money
and at the end of the day your
retirement account is is losing on its
investment One Step where they're just
just since while we're on the on the
kick of pissing you off here so
so with one hand okay the black rocks of
the world are pressuring Exxon and
Chevron and others to effectively drill
for Less oil with emissions caps turns
out those companies have to drop oil
production projects to meet those Net
Zero standards by 2050. guess who's oh
no let me ask you just a question what
your net reaction is you may know where
I'm going with this so you may probably
get it right do you think those projects
are still proceeding or do you think
that they actually just got dropped in
the interest of staving off Global
emissions which do you think it is
between the two
um dropped no wrong answer actually
projects are proceeding they're just
proceeding under new ownership
so the firms that are buying up these
projects from Chevron include the likes
of Petro China on the other side of the
world
now you ask the final question guess
who's one of the large shareholders of
petrochina
it is none other than BlackRock the very
firm that was actually pressuring the
ex-hunted Chevrons of the world over
here to drop those kinds of projects
that is how deep this runs you don't
know why because if you go to China and
they're going to establish an ESG agenda
and scope three emissions targets
they're going to tell you to get the
heck out and to shut the door on your
way out because we built a great Chinese
wall the Great Wall that stops you from
entering the Chinese market if you're
going to mess with our companies but
actually if you're also one of those
firms that's doing it to the us we'll
roll out the red carpet and that's
exactly why BlackRock became the first
foreign owner to win a license to sell
mutual funds in China a few years ago
because they were doing the bidding of
the CCP so this runs deep right and when
you have when you have sort of
concentrated nodes of private public
power in the United States that's what
lends it to capture even by other
governments like the CCP in a truly
decentralized free market system or in a
truly decentralized Democratic body
politic by the way that doesn't lend
itself to capture including by Foreign
actors but when you have that level of
concentration of both Capital but also
Capital coordinated with State action
that's what lends itself to capture from
abroad and that's the game the CCP has
actually mastered to this brings me to
something I've been talking about for a
very long time because we have seen a
lot of Western Elites a lot of Wall
Street firms prop up China and I think
they're using China as a vessel not only
to test out their Draconian Big Brother
totalitarian uh policies but more
importantly I think China is the
direction the whole world is going in
and we see individuals like Bill Gates
literally advise the Chinese government
I don't think that's a that's a
coincidence here what do you think is
really going on here how do you think
this is developing because for me
personally I'm seeing this as an attempt
by many Elites to make China as an
example for the rest of the world Klaus
Schwab even openly talks about this Bill
Gates openly compliments China with
their zero covet policies when they're
actually creating humanitarian crises
and violating human rights on so many
different levels so to me China is the
playground of the elites they're using
it for the future for everyone is that
correct or is that too much I I view it
uh just in Reverse whereas I think that
with people who you call the elites are
really just the circus monkeys okay Tim
Cook and Larry Fink are XI jinping's
circus monkeys he will say jump they
will ask how high because it actually
comes down to money right so so the game
we played in this country and by the way
there's not it's not just Democrat
Republic this is Democrats and
Republicans by the way starting in the
1990s had this philosophy of democratic
capitalism in the United States the way
it went was we're going to export Big
Macs and happy meals and somehow we're
going to imagine that spreads democracy
to places like China we're going to use
our money to get them to be more like us
what China realized and they're always
playing a longer game than we are is
that actually
we could turn that on its head
we can use our money access to our
Market to to get America to be more like
us or One Step better they realize they
could use our own money to get us to be
more like us because we're the ones who
invested there in the first place and
there's that old neoliberals neoliberal
idea that as a nation progresses
economically that naturally Liberty and
democracy will follow so that was the
idea with all the foreign
that's the idea with the foreign direct
investment to China not only do we get
all these cheaper Goods but hey we also
get to democratize them we get to make
them exactly Western like us uh you know
I grew up in China partially yeah um not
only in Hong Kong but also in Shanghai
and it was shocking absolutely
unbelievable the amount of progress and
development that happened while I was
living under there but the thing is they
I think they overestimated the draw that
American neoliberalism will have because
as China has gotten more developed it's
actually I mean people say it's
communist it's not really communist it's
the strange hybrid of state-run
authoritarianism they're actually seeing
the decadences of the West and they are
using the capital that the West has
essentially transferred over to them in
order to combat it directly right and we
see this through Tick Tock Chinese Tick
Tock is not the same as Western Tick
Tock you go on Western Tick Tock and
they're offering you up videos of trans
non-binary whatever Chinese Tick Tock is
actually educational math and
Engineering exactly and that's that's
not an accident that China is very aware
of the societal ills that the left had
or sorry that the West has basically the
same thing and they're actually trying
to encourage them abroad while limiting
it at home thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time